so I have the function G of X is equal
to 9 times 8 to the X minus 1 power and
it's defined for X for X being a
positive or if X is a positive integer
if X is a positive positive integer so
we could say the domain of this function
or all of the valid inputs here are
positive integer so 1 2 3 4 5 on and on
and on so this is an explicitly defined
function what I now want to do is to
write a recursive definition of this
exact same function that give it an X it
will give the exact same outputs so
let's first just try to understand the
inputs and outputs here so let's make a
little table let's make a table here and
let's think about what what happens when
we put in various X's into this function
definition so the domain is positive
integer so let's try a couple of them 1
2 3 4 and then see what the
corresponding G of X is G of X so when X
is equal to 1 G of X is 9 times 8 to the
1 minus 1 power 9 times 8 to the 0 power
or 9 times 1 so G of X is going to be
just 9 when X is 2 when X is 2 what's
going to happen will be 9 times 8 to the
2 minus 1 so that's the same thing as 9
times 8 to the first power and that's
just going to be 9 times 8 so that is 72
actually let me just write it that way
let me write it as just 9 times 8 9
times 8 then when X is equal to 3 what's
going on here well this is going to be 3
minus 1 is 2 so it's going to be 8
squared so it's going to be 9 times 8
squared so we could write that as 9
times 8 times 8 I think you see a little
bit of a pattern forming when X is 4
this is going to be 8 to the 4 minus 1
power 8 to the third power so that's 9
times 8 times 8 times 8 so this gives us
a good clue about how we would define
this recursively notice if our first
term when x equals 1 is 9 every term
after that is 8 x is 8 times the
preceding term is 8 times the preceding
term 8 times the preceding term 8 times
the preceding term so let's define that
as a recursive function so first we'll
define our base case so we could say G
of X G and I'll do this in a new color
because I mean over using the red I like
the blue G of X well we can define our
base case it's going to be equal to 9 if
X is equal to 1 G of x equals 9 if x
equals 1 so that took care of that right
over there and then if it equals
anything else if it equals anything else
it equals the previous G of X so if
we're looking at if we're looking at
let's go all the way down to X minus 1
and then an X so if this if this entry
right over here if this entry right over
here is G of X minus 1 G of X minus 1
however many times we multiply the eight
and we have a 9 in front so this is G of
X minus 1 we know that G of X we know
that this one right over here is going
to be the previous entry G of X minus 1
the previous entry that's the previous
entry times 8 times 8 times 8 so we
could write that right here so times 8
so for any other X other than 1 G of X
is equal to the previous entry so it's G
of I'll do that in that blue color G of
X minus 1 G of X minus 1 times 8 if X is
greater than 1 or X is X is integer
integer greater greater than one now
let's verify that this actually works so
let's draw another table here let's draw
another table here so once again we're
going to have X and we're going to have
G of X but this time we're going to use
this recursive definition for G of X and
the reason why it's recursive is it's
referring to itself
its own definition it's saying hey G of
X well if X doesn't equal one it's going
to be G of X minus one it's using the
function itself but we'll see that it
actually does work out so let's see when
X is equal to one x equals one so G of
one well if x equals one its equal to
9/2 equal to nine so that was pretty
straightforward what happens when x
equals two well when x equals two this
case doesn't apply anymore we go down to
this case so it's going to be when X is
equal to two it's going to be equivalent
to G of 2 minus 1 let me write this down
it's going to be equivalent to G of 2
minus 1 times 8 which is the same thing
as G of 1 times 8 and what's G of 1 well
G of 1 is right over here
G of 1 is 9 so this is going to be equal
to 9 times 8 exactly what we got over
here and of course this was equivalent
to G of 2 so let me write this this is G
of G of 2 let me scroll over a little
bit so I don't get all squinched up so
now let's go to 3 let's go to 3 and
right now write G of 3 first so G of 3 G
of 3 is equal to we're going to this
case it's equal to G of 3 minus 1 3
minus 1 times 8 so that's equal to G of
2 times 8 well what's G of 2 well G of 2
we already figured out is 9 times 8 so
it's equal to 9 times 8 that's G of 2
times 8 again and so you see we get the
exact same results so this is the
recursive definition of this function